hey what's going on it's bill burr and
it's time for the Thursday afternoon
just before Friday Monday morning
podcast and I'm just checking in on you
I'm checking in to see how's your week
going you're on [ __ ] Thursday man
you're on the East Coast it's almost
lunchtime
all right by the time this comes out
it'll be lunchtime what are you gonna
get huh
you gotta go out and get something heavy
are you gonna start the weekend right
let's go out and get something healthy
bring the stomach down a little bit you
feel a little more comfortable right a
little more confident you go out to the
club's with your button-down shirt you
belly's not pressing against it right
well you guys do it put my AK well your
buttons are doing like the iron cross
hanging on to both sides of your shirt
like you don't need that make life a
little easy why is this [ __ ] thing
only on one goddamn channel no I'll
figure it out that's it you know I sit
nope the elevator only goes to the
fourth floor
it's where I am right now with my anger
no more going to the penthouse okay I've
downsized
my anger life I've moved down to a floor
that I feel is just a little more
affordable and everybody can relax
around me you know what it is is I don't
have any time I think that that's
something I feel like that triggers me
Billy no time Billy no time they call
him Billy no time you know my wife knows
I don't have any time but what is she -
the [ __ ] was that was it yelling just
set off one of my kids toys I like that
it's like a sound effects what did I
just yell I'll see if I can make that
but she's got this one friggin toy this
[ __ ] it's [ __ ] crazy I like it cuz
there's all these different musical
instruments and it teaches the kids
about it
but I swear the guy the guy's energy
it's like Willie Aames and Charles in
charge you know he's like Charles it's
the same things like pop and rock pop
and rock pop and rock pick four
instruments it's a trumpet it's like
buddy relax I don't want to hear you
play an instrument when you're all
[ __ ] wound up like that now that
constipated [ __ ] sound coming out of
your instrument Miles Davis turning
around giving you that look on the
bandstand relax a little bit bop and
rock pop and rock hey Scootaloo booboo
is that a trumpet right you want to live
in there I'm not a musical guy [ __ ] you
almost goddamn comedian speaking of
which I want to thank Madison Square
Garden for uh Anna Rory Rose Garden for
having me on the Garden of Dreams and
this is really great charity where they
basically you know underprivileged kids
kids who are sick and all that they got
a dream and they come out and they make
it they make it come true it was really
nice it was funny as I was doing the the
press there I was doing the press and
Jeffrey Gurian was then I always [ __ ]
with him I always have a great time with
them but uh what are the ladies and
lives like do you know what this you
know what this charity is about you know
and I just seen some kid you know you
know wheelchair kid on a walk or
whatever and it's just like oh god do
you know what this charity is for I was
like no no I don't know I don't so I'm
gonna come off like an [ __ ] but the
reason why I said that was because I
really didn't feel like talking about it
you know once you have like a kid it
just it affects you like you have
something to apply it to where before
was like oh my god I feel bad for that
enters like I felt the whole [ __ ]
thing the parents the whole thing tell
us about the charity can you go through
the emotion of it no no I won't be I
don't know what it is it's Madison
Square Garden they asked me to come out
here so anyway I go and I do this show
[ __ ] monster lineup of comics
everybody [ __ ] killed fortunately I
went on during the middle Seinfeld had
closed it out Jon Stewart went on a
second álast
and Michael che
Jesus Christ he came in [ __ ] murdered
came in from SNL still at his jacket on
just walked onstage [ __ ] murders
leaves [ __ ] joke assess and who else
was on it John Mulaney
[ __ ] murdering Liza Schlesinger
murdered Brian Regan brainless Helbig
the show Brian Regan opened that's how
[ __ ] amazing the show us so I was
happy sure I forgot somebody I know I
did I know there was more than that who
else was on it come on bill think I
don't [ __ ] steve Schirripa hosted the
thing one of the crew guys and Madison
where gardeners name was I mean it was
cool we were going through the bowels of
the place going over to the the theater
at Madison Square Garden where Eddie
Murphy recorded raw I always think about
that when I was there and when I'm there
and we were going through we had to go
up the elevator and they had all the
Ottawa Senators like hockey bags they
were loading them in because the Rangers
were playing playing them the next night
and lo and behold the next night I'm
back in LA cuz I got up at 4:00 a.m. to
get back to my lovely wife and kid as
you do was it dad because it's not about
you anymore what do you think he gonna
get some sleep there dad don't think so
I got on the [ __ ] plane flew back
here and then I ended up watching like a
period and a half of the game and lo and
behold they cut to the they cut to some
highlights from the garden got in it
didn't show the show thank Christ I was
a little rusty I'm not gonna lie to you
I hadn't died much stayin to bite and
after I did the did my special I was
like I'm gonna take some time for me you
know what I mean put my feet up and just
sort of just what was that [ __ ] word
those kinds of people use that regroup
just allow myself to just realign
my synapses no I just didn't feel like
going out or anything and I was I was
[ __ ] yeah wiped out and I felt like a
fighter that didn't spar you know just
be like man I'm the champ I got the belt
right I just knocked out you know my
last set was my my state of special
[ __ ] knocked that out I'm gonna
[ __ ] champ over here and I got the
old right there Fred the second I walked
out this so I me and it a little bit in
the beginning then I got it going and oh
my god had this [ __ ] hilarious moment
my set where you know I was making fun
of Michelle Obama because how do you not
you know what I mean the level that
she's been gassed up to it she's the
president's wife all right let everybody
relax
that was basically my angle so you know
you know you know [ __ ] you know all
the women are gonna [ __ ] lose their
minds especially white women who also
don't have jobs you know they get you
know who are you know a lot of rich
people there right so I was you know I
was pushing their buttons yeah I mean in
fairness the audience I was being a [ __ ]
and I was saying you know how being a
first lady it's not a job I'm extending
what all the excitement's about it's not
a job right and so I keep setting off
that toy so I say and I just so you know
I can't see into the crowd right so I
just look into the blackness of like the
tenth row this voice that I just heard
yeah I thought you think it's a job yes
yes
I'm like alright ma'am I want to do me a
favor you tell me how the [ __ ] that's a
job and the woman goes first of all it's
sir turned out it was a dude right so
then immediately you feel like this
[ __ ] post me to tension a a
gender-neutral bathroom all his [ __ ]
energy and I just went like well you
know okay tell you you got a
high-pitched voice you sound like a
woman
I you know something I was really not
enjoying this time and now I've realized
that this is one of the greatest times
ever to be a [ __ ] comedian the amount
of fun that you can have and there was
not you know you sound like a woman and
you know what nowadays just say well
what is a woman sound like you know what
a woman sounds like you know what a guy
sounds like you know the bass [ __ ]
thing I hate when people do that though
when I'm during the OJ trial when that
guy said it sounded like a black guy you
never he's like what does a black guy
say you know what does an Irish guy
sound like what does a German guy what
does a French guy sound like this
accents not saying everybody sounds like
that you know what I mean but if you met
a black guy going like oh how are you at
top of the mornin to ya find out how
much you can you'd be like this guy
who's [ __ ] with me but because it's
trial you have to take into
consideration that this might be the
anomaly now I understand that but to say
that somebody's saying you know that
sounded like an Asian dude that there's
something like [ __ ] I don't know
clannish about that I guess there could
be speaking of that way I would tell you
one time I was in San Francisco right
visiting the bathhouses and I got into a
cab and this asian dude was driving and
he had the he sounded like he was on
[ __ ] he Hawk so there is always that
exception I swear to god straight-up
Asian dude and he was just going on man
I hate it's traffic out here it's
ridiculous and I'm looking at the dude
me it's this guy [ __ ] with me hey how
long y'all gonna be out here in San
Francisco and I was just like dude I
gotta ask where the [ __ ] are you from
and he laughs he's like man I grew up in
Tennessee I know it's [ __ ] up to hear
me talking like this Bo where it grew up
everybody did then he started telling me
how he did all this extra work now he
was an extra and clean clean Eastwood's
uh one of those Dirty Harry movies
and I got his phone number and I back
this when I was back on Opie and Anthony
I was like oh my god we got to get this
guy on the show so there is an exception
but I mean they told but this also
that's not a reason to what are the kids
called now you've been canceled
[Laughter]
you sound Latino just exactly what does
that mean I tell you that time I was
going to Charlie Murphy's funeral and I
had packed hastily you know what I mean
cuz you never know when someone's gonna
pass away all of a sudden it's like [ __ ]
we got to go so I and I forgot to pack
my underwear is there so where I was
staying in New York was had become the
gay part of town right and because it
didn't used to be gay used to be [ __ ]
Shady and then all the gay guys moved in
and then you know what happens all of a
sudden there's nice restaurants there's
a nightlife there's [ __ ] mood lighting
it's it's it's awesome right so right
across the street from where I was
staying was this clothing store and I'm
not gonna lie to you you know in the
[ __ ] windows they definitely had like
the the mannequin with the leather
underwear in the Hat but I mean I had
the ghost but I saw they had other
[ __ ] t-shirts in there so I went in
there trying to find some underwear so I
figured that was just like an aisle
right the dog collared [ __ ] aisle right
so I go into this [ __ ] place and I'm
trying to find underwear and all that
got it like the [ __ ] I'm like I
finally find an underwear cut that I can
wear to a funeral all right
rather than wearin the Greg Louganis
goes to Brazil [ __ ] cut right so I
finally find the cut and then on I know
I've told this story before but there's
always new listeners right on the
waistband it said nasty pig you know and
in the funeral you know the the service
is like [ __ ] 90 minutes away it's out
in Jersey and in time he's become an
issue so I walk up to the counter and
this is dude standing there talking to
the person behind the register and I
kind of interrupted I was excused I
don't mean to interrupt I go do you have
any like like
mainstream underwear that's what I said
you have any mainstream underwear and
the guy got offended
he's like define mainstream I just
stayed in the pocket I was like oh I
don't know it doesn't say nasty Pig on
on the waistband and then he had nothing
he was trying to do that like you know
trying to make me out to be like
homophobic I can't [ __ ] come on to my
wife off the road with underwear that
says nasty Pig on it honey I swear to
God I was going to a funeral
and I needed some underwear it was a
glitch right I'll set him Gus Grissom of
[ __ ] underwear anyways so that ended
up being a lot of fun and I finished my
set and I said thank you god bless
everybody including you sir with your
high-pitched voice so I guess I was a
bit of a cut but um so last night right
and I on it I really did not like that
feeling of being like rusty or whatever
so I mean already look rusty hey
remember rusty Jones hello goodbye rest
hello rusty Jones goodbye rusty cars
should be able to make a living doing
that writing jingles eight-second songs
I'm a pepper he's a pepper she's a
pepper we're a pepper wouldn't you like
to be a pepper to be a pepper drag dr.
pepper
Bamm house in the Hollywood Hills horse
by the pool cocaine on the piano stays
are all gone I said the second you make
it somebody takes it on the internet and
then they do a mash-up right what the
[ __ ] I don't know the coca-cola song
I don't know how the [ __ ] it works
anymore but that was a job when I was
growing up you see how about you'd have
a party that there would be somebody at
your house one guy was a milkman and
another person wrote jingles for
commercial
alright there was always somebody in
actuaries just sizing everybody up
trying to figure out when you're gonna
die
well he's already twenty-two pounds
overweight far as my visual estimate
goes and that is a second helping of
cream of spinach can't be good for the
arteries I'm gonna I'm gonna say that
guy's gonna tap out around 57
that was a dangerous age when I was
growing up 57 you know that's when you
were in the red zone of having a heart
attack 57 [ __ ] 63-61 a lot of guys
dropped at 61 which didn't seem like a
big deal when I was like five six you
know [ __ ] guy was born in like the
nineteen nineteen OS he had a great run
right like I was alive when Babe Ruth
this was in shape when when you all of a
sudden you have fifty staring down the
barrel 51 in June oh my god oh my god I
was uh I want so I go to the airport
right like pick up 10:05 is what I
actually wasn't right and I get to the
airport like 5:30 cruised right out to
[ __ ] JFK alright I got my I got my
ticket on my cell phone
alright I'm a modern man I'm not
checking any bags I'm a little [ __ ]
mister technology so I'm pre checked TSA
right I [ __ ] go through that [ __ ] and
I got my ticket and I just [ __ ] I go I
just put my phone down a thing and I and
I I set it down on the thing and I on my
cell phone case I got I got this cluster
of pictures of me and my lovely daughter
right so I set it down and you know
there's a woman there so you know they
can't resist a kid she sees and she just
goes oh yeah isn't she a beauty and she
goes yeah she goes is that your
granddaughter oh how did that hurt
and I laughed I said no it's my daughter
I go I got a late start oh and then I
just limped through [ __ ] security I
had such a [ __ ] spring in my step I'm
like I haven't boozed
130 days right my skin's clearing up
I'm drinking [ __ ] smoothies I'm
looking younger than than my years in
sheep's oh my she just said she sent me
she [ __ ] [ __ ] strapped me and
right on top of the rocket just shot me
right back to the reality of my [ __ ]
age man oh man that killed me [ __ ]
killed me I'm like alladia I thought I'd
tell this story and then have a joke at
the end of it but all I have is just the
raw emotion of that that really [ __ ]
hurt you know so see there you go ladies
there's a pressure this is stigma when
you're a bald redheaded male Grandda but
the reality is I am I am bold am i if I
had a kid at 25 my kid would be coming
up on 26 and if my kid had a kid about
the same time I did then [ __ ] it I would
I would be old enough to be a
grandfather
see so I'm not gonna get mad at her I'm
not gonna write TSA calm and be like I
was so triggered when somebody stated a
fact about my age you know what I'm
gonna take it and we're taking what did
I want to talk about here oh I got so
much not so much [ __ ] I got a couple
emails some he's [ __ ] f-1 snobs
because I was talking about how rooting
for Ferrari is like rooting for the
Kansas City Chiefs I was painting them
as an underdog now even though I clearly
stated that I just started watching like
[ __ ] three four years ago Ferrari has
not been doing well all right second
place
hey that yeah that's deer you're the
first loser so what I said was accurate
and there shouldn't they're talking down
to this father who looks like a
grandfather talking down to me this
person who has difficulty reading out
loud talking down to me the hero of this
podcast the greatest person on this
podcast right now is me and it's not
because I'm I'm the only voice it's
because I'm the only one who votes now
giving me [ __ ] like I didn't understand
that Ferrari is I know what a Ferrari is
you [ __ ] morons
everybody knows what a Ferrari
I know their history I actually read off
I read this book called the limit about
the first f1 American f1 champion one of
the great [ __ ] books I ever read I
wish I didn't give it away I always give
away the books absolutely [ __ ] love
that book and I understand understand
okay I know where it's at all right I'm
just saying the last couple of years I
mean ever since I've been watching this
sports since like 2015-2016 whenever the
[ __ ] I started it's just been Mercedes
alright I'm getting sick of it you know
the same way you guys are sick of the
Patriots I would like to see Ferrari
make a run although since then I did see
that new guy John what's-his-face there
the other the new driver was not Kimi
räikkönen then who the new guy driving
for Ferraris like ah man you know well I
guess we got lucky that the safety car
came out and he was really positive
about it and that made me that gave me
some hope it gave me some hope by the
way we can have a [ __ ] benefit for
[ __ ] Daniel Ricciardo yet you know
they're always doing stand-up benefits I
want to do a stand-up benefit to get
that guy a [ __ ] team that can give
him a car that's gonna be able to finish
the [ __ ] race that poor bastard
I swear to God if they take the smile
away from that man
you know that's gets really gonna be a
difficult [ __ ] thing to watch
somebody so young so full of life
you know twinkle in his eye how many
[ __ ] times can you just be driving
crushing it and all of a sudden your car
just shuts off you know
or for some reason somebody puts a mogul
in the goddamn grass you try not to get
sideswipe when you go over just to con
ter under the grass and the front of
your car [ __ ] explodes I don't get it
the guy's [ __ ] snake [ __ ] snake [ __ ]
snake bit sorry oh so I finally I saw
the that I tell you guys I saw the I saw
the MotoGP from Argentina I got a lot of
questions alright so I take a sip of a
green smoothie a green smoothie you guys
want a good recipe for a smoothie
green smoothie here it is
cup of iced cup of almond milk sorry
starting over again
quarter cup ice a cup of almond milk a
banana a cup of spinach a cup of walnuts
I mean on a cup a tablespoon of
all-natural honey two tablespoon of
instant oatmeal and one tablespoon of
almond butter just try to get all
natural everything this is how I do it I
put the ice the almond milk and the
spinach in first and then maybe like
some of the honey because what happens
is you know the way you do it like
sometimes it can turn into like a shake
if there's too much ice but there's not
enough ice near then I blend that then I
put the paint I put the banana in there
first and then I put in the the peanut
but the oats and then the peanut butter
or whatever and that way it stays on top
of the banana and it doesn't sink all
the way [ __ ] down because like it's
it's really the peanut butter and the
honey it's gonna stick down to the
bottom and won't be part of the [ __ ]
mix so however I just said that don't
put the honey in where I said that flip
the oats in the honey and mix it up that
way and you should be good I do like to
stew separate mixes there you go drink
that [ __ ] drink your breakfast be a
champion be like a dad who looks like a
grandfather
oh god that [ __ ] killed me you know I
swear to god it just four men actually
gave a [ __ ] about men with red beards I
would have gone out and bought some like
if they were selling it on the plane and
I would have been quietly crying to
myself as I combed it into my chin
alright here's my question about the
MotoGP I don't get what the [ __ ] is with
Marc Marquez his [ __ ] motorcycle
where it's just they even called it you
know he might just take off and this
could be a boring race and then the guy
quickly correct himself not saying that
it's gonna people the guy just [ __ ]
he got a good start and he got out front
and he had like a [ __ ] 15-second lead
by the middle of the race or something
something crazy I don't understand why
his bike is so much faster I thought the
Ducati Tsar the Duke at ease we're all
unlike the same level but he just pulled
away like you know he had the iroc-z and
everybody else had the rally sport or
the Berlinetta you know the Firebird
versus the Trans Am I
it's the exact opposite of f1 so then
the whole [ __ ] race the exciting part
of the race was watching the video so
and Valentino Rossi battling for second
place and he would Marc Marquez was so
far out into the front that they just
had him in a little square on the upper
right hand side of the my computer
screen here well we just watched
everybody else battle and I don't
understand what happened to Jorge
Lorenzo did he pushed the wrong button
because he's also Drive riding a Honda
and then they were all bitching about
the video so and his little aerodynamic
thing that cooled off his back tire they
thought that was a ridiculous advantage
and then the very next race all of a
sudden this guy you know Marc Marquez
just takes off and it's a video so still
has that thing cool in his back tire I
guess what they should have done because
they were so busy [ __ ] with each
other trying to pass each other racing
what they should have done is just
accepted that the video so was in second
they all got in behind each other like
the peloton and vis that I said in bike
racing and eventually they would cut
through the wind and catch up with the
guy and then once they caught up with
them then it could be like all right
let's start racing again is that legal
to do that to actually become a team to
catch the [ __ ] guy who's already
eight seconds in front of you I don't
know
and then lastly Cal Crutchlow
says name he got [ __ ] on that race he
got [ __ ] all right he had an
incredible [ __ ] start to the naked
eye he didn't start too soon and the
fact that there's a goddamn computer now
like people's brains are not as good as
a [ __ ] computer can't see that thing
so he doesn't know he's cheating he just
thought he got a good [ __ ] start hey
though man they [ __ ] that guy over
they [ __ ] him over alright so there
you go this is my little motorcycle talk
I'm gonna read some advertising and then
I'm gonna wrap this [ __ ] podcast up
and I'm gonna get on with my busy day
here alright oh here we go but oh don't
do me andhis me undies Billy is old and
gray doo doo doo doo me undies me undies
that's what the ladies say you have a
beautiful [ __ ] granddaughter
that's not my granddaughter right
nothing rhymes with daughter I'm too
[ __ ] old to make it some [ __ ] work
somebody get me a journal at all and
some soft [ __ ] underwears ok BuzzFeed
said this about me undies they feel like
actual heaven against your skin we're
going to assume heaven is really soft
in this context well don't you pay but
BuzzFeed or do they just review [ __ ] I
don't ask men well isn't that a nice
magazine I'd like to be asked things
feel like I'm being heard ask men said
they feel like silk drenched in hand
lotion silk drench and hint like I know
hand lotion makes your hands soft and I
know silk is soft so if you combine both
those but you also jerk off with lotion
and if you if you put that on the fabric
now the fabric is wet and it's gonna be
sticking to your balls alright this is
why you don't ask men thinks these
undies are so soft they make Bob Ross's
voice sound like Gilbert Godfrey they
are so soft that Kenny G thinks about
them to get inspired to write his next
song Kenny G taking a hit there what did
Kenny do me undies uses the coveted
micro modal modal fabric that is a full
three times softer than cotton take that
big cotton
big puffy oh yeah and Cotton's also
white to you fabric toxicity fabric
patriotical [ __ ] speaking of prints why
not match your bottom half with your
better half and get a matching prints
for you and your partner me undies is
also do they have like underwear for
alternative couples lifestyles says
nasty pig on one and says nasty Pig two
on the other one the undies is also the
go-to for the softest loungewear on this
side of the Mississippi hangout and
they're super comfy lounge pants and
onesies yes my undies makes onesies and
they're incredible beyond zis has a
great offer from my listeners for any
first-time purchasers when you order me
undies you get 15% off and free shipping
this is a no-brainer get 15% off the
most comfortable underwears you will
ever put on to get your 15% off your
first pair free shipping and a lot of
results oz less guaranteed go to me
undies dot-com / / that's me undies
dot-com / / e un di es it's like the me
to thing except it says undies hashtag
me undies alright butcher box everybody
uh here we go
butcher box delivers healthy 100%
grass-fed grass-finished beef free-range
organic chicken and heritage breed pork
did you guys see napal got si special
yet the Tennessee kid it's [ __ ] a
guy's absolutely brilliant he has a
great bit on free-range chickens versus
the ones that they that were not free to
range about it's on Netflix streaming
now look at that it's an ad within an ad
the incredible quality of butcher box
meats start with the commitment to
raising animals humanely and free of
antibiotics and hormones
cook with the peace of mind knowing you
are eating healthy high-quality meat
each box comes with least eight to 11
pounds of meat which is enough for 24
individual size meals if you're a city
slicker but if you some big fast boat
driving you can choose from five
different boxes all beef lady's beef and
chicken beef and
pork mixed box for you progressive
people custom box lets you choose your
own cuts that's for the conservative you
know that's for the people who want to
keep their meat separate once via will
only take these they are the I discusses
he meets my favorite cut of meat is the
heritage breed pork oh man I have a
[ __ ] recipe i I was at the airport
there Oh grant grandfather burr here and
Grandpa Burr and I was uh it was it was
basically show now you can make all
these meals in just one pot you know
what I mean you know those great [ __ ]
things that comfort food that's gonna
make you [ __ ] blow up I got a good
one for pork chops that I'm gonna try
this weekend oh I can't wait I really am
like a grandfather I'm excited about
cooking pork chops alright this month
butcher box is offering the unlimited
breakfast breakfast bundle what is this
this includes two packages of bacon and
two pounds of breakfast sausages all for
free in your first box our bacon is the
best bacon you've ever had its whole
thirty approved well I don't know what
that means what the thirty people run in
the bacon world uncured nitrate and
sugar free this sausage is a healthy
authentic version of a classic style
pork sausage my mouth is watering like
literally reading this simply seasoned
with salt and pepper and sage oh my god
what a way to start the day I need that
I would start crying looking across the
table my phobia what's the matter honey
right now new members will get two
packages of bacon and two pounds of
breakfast sausage added to your first
box for free plus you'll get $20 off
your first box go now while supplies
last as this is a limited time offer
these people know how to do it alright
you want Americans to buy your beef you
dangle free bacon and sausage in their
[ __ ] face and you set a timer Jesus
Christ the amount of [ __ ]
you-know-what so you know the amount of
[ __ ] people in overalls right now
that are like half hard listening to
this overalls are like the
zees for rednecks you know that's when
they know that they grew up ain't got no
sleeves and my a buddy you don't know
who you [ __ ] with ain't got no sleeves
or feet on my onesies I walk outside my
onesie that's how I do it
all right that's the podcast everybody
please enjoy the musical interlude and
then there's gonna be a hat another half
hour bonus here of a Thursday afternoon
just before Friday Monday morning
podcast greatest hit an episode from
earlier oh I didn't mention last night
so I went out I did two sets that's
right because I didn't like feeling
rusty and I I got this whole new chunk
and it came last night and I had a great
set and then Bryan Callen probably said
some of the nicest [ __ ] anybody said to
me about as a comedian I think he's
absolutely [ __ ] brilliant so I'm
actually gonna call him today and thank
him for the compliment it put me on a
stand up high you know which being the
age that I am you know I you know I got
called a grandfather nice and I have an
AARP card and I've still never [ __ ]
used it okay and if you're young and you
don't know what it is that's that's
awesome enjoy the part of your life
where you don't know what an AARP you're
qualified yet for one of those [ __ ]
things all right that's the podcast
enjoy the music have a great weekend you
[ __ ] and I will see you on Monday
[Music]
hey what's going on it's bill Bert's the
Monday morning podcast for Monday April
4th 2011 or 2011 as I saw it so
succinctly put this weekend by the great
comedian Patton Oswalt that's how he
said it he was on stage I was doing a
show with him the Kevin and bean April
foolishness show and I noticed at some
point at the Gibson Amphitheatre by the
way formerly known as the universal
amphitheater for blues brother fans you
might recognize that name right remember
that good evening ladies and gentlemen
welcome to the universal Amphitheatre
here it is something something going on
1985 so much of music here today is
pre-program electronic disco that's
where the [ __ ] they did that and they
were opening for Steve Martin at the
height of Steve Martin's career when he
had the white suit with the bow and
arrow going through it so that's the
second year in a row I've got to do that
wonderful program show performance
whatever the [ __ ] you call it and it was
an awesome night of comedy but there was
something learnt and all the filth and
funery that I saw that night was Patton
said 2011 so that's how I'm saying it
for the rest of the year because I can't
say mm and I have to slow down 2011 2011
see it runs together 2011 all of a
sudden everybody in the room relaxes hey
well with the friend we thought that
that redheaded guy was was you know
who's left-handed some of the times was
a spawn of the devil you know that's
what they used to think about redheads
and people who wrote with their left
hand so basically I would if it was
still the 1800s I would be getting his
[ __ ] slapped out of me and one of those
[ __ ] schools you know that they used
to have on little house in the Prairie
we had grades 2 through 8 we're all
sitting in the same room tell me that
wasn't inappropriate behavior going on
there you know
you're a senior in high school right all
of a sudden the freshman girls come in
there's always one pervert your grade
would descend on to someone who was
basically a [ __ ] child at that point
you can't tell me back in the day in the
1800s when people got married at 14 so
they could pool together their shilling
so they could go buy a [ __ ] plot of
land and some oxen huh you're telling me
some eighth grader wasn't rolling up on
a fourth grader you know like some
Catholic [ __ ] Prius I'm like I start
that goddamn debating it speaking of
which hey you know what for some reason
the theme to Laverne & Shirley is in my
head today we're gonna do it well think
of that - been in my head before me once
in a while TV that I watched way too
much back in the day pops into my head
but anyways getting back to the the
Catholic Church thing somebody sent me a
little Bible thing said the dinosaurs
are called behemoths in the Bible and
about outer space aliens ships
spaceships abductions his talk talked
about in Ezekiel one and these are from
in the King James Bible now after all
these years of trash in the Bible I'd
have I ever mentioned to you guys that I
haven't even read the [ __ ] thing oh
I've tried to read the thing but it's
all he said it under us and then the
[ __ ] Polynesians said to the Persians
I mean I can't I can't get through it
it's like trying to read straight
Shakespeare but as far as I remember
going to church they said that uh you
know earth was created in six days on
the seventh day God rested and I created
Adam and Eve and they were in they were
in Eden hanging out right then all of a
sudden you know he lays down some rules
he says hey listen you guys are in
paradise I just don't want you to go
over there and eat an apple off of that
[ __ ] tree you know is that so goddamn
hard to not eat a piece of fruit who
gives a [ __ ] it's fruit no one wants to
eat fruit the only people eat fruit or
kids whose parents are making a medium
okay vegetarians and some 50 year old
Wall Street guy oh just suffered his
third heart attack then maybe 11 Apple
so he doesn't die but other than that
how easy is it not to eat an apple right
but Eve the stupid [ __ ] [ __ ] that
she is you know you're not gonna tell me
okay I can't do something and because
she's abroad and you can't punch her in
the face what does she have to worry
about huh
who the [ __ ] is this god guy to tell me
I can't go and have an apple so what
does she do she marches right over there
with the pubic hair blowing in the
[ __ ] wind because there's no shame at
this point cuz there's been no sin
everything's great you can walk around
and go pet a cheetah it doesn't
immediately or a leopard it doesn't
immediately grab you by the throat
[ __ ] snap your neck and then drag you
up in a tree so the Lions can't get to
it or somebody else maybe a [ __ ]
baboon you know with its psycho goddamn
teeth do you know let's one of the one
of the [ __ ] major adversaries for a
leopard as a [ __ ] baboon I never knew
that [ __ ] they got those giant teeth who
would have known you know very agile
left-to-right sort of movement like a
water bug these insane things but hey
let's get back to the Bible as far as I
remember it right so they go Z you know
walking up to the [ __ ] apple tree
like some one of those Victoria's Secret
[ __ ] walking down the first [ __ ]
runway although she's not wearing heels
she's just walking and she never steps
on a Brock doesn't step on some glass
from a broken miller lite bottle cuz
she's in paradise she walks right over
there
and some snake starts yeah that's what
happens some snake starts yapping in her
ear right like some douche on Facebook
who finds your wife and her semi hot
pictures starts emailing her right
worming his way into the relationship
alright so this [ __ ] goes up and what
does she do she reaches up and she takes
a bite of fruit
she eats an apple as far as I've been
told part of this nutritious breakfast
part of a balanced diet sheets of
[ __ ] Apple maybe she wanted to be
regular right so she eats the Apple and
then God goes what the [ __ ] what the
[ __ ] did I tell ya the one thing I say
not to do and you got to go do it
go [ __ ] yourself that's the end of
paradise and next thing you know she's
putting a leaf over a [ __ ] clam all
right
Adams over there he didn't do [ __ ] but
evidently he gets punished too because
it's religion you know the punishment
never has to make sense it just has to
be really [ __ ] scary so now they're
both [ __ ] now all of a sudden the
Leopards want to [ __ ] take a bite out
of their ass so they got to get
sharpened sticks and all this type of
[ __ ] right according to the Bible all of
this that happened like [ __ ] a couple
hundred thousand years ago and then one
day some nerd who's not getting [ __ ]
he's so [ __ ] hard up he just starts
digging in the ground you know he's got
all that sexual frustration he just
keeps digging in the ground and one day
finds these dinosaur bones then a way
[ __ ] older than the Adam and Eve
story so it kind of kills the whole
goddamn thing now that as far as I know
it's the story in the Bible how the
Bible goes down and that's why people on
the science side question the Bible I
like I said I haven't read it
alright so people who've read it can you
give me the cheat notes are you bible
thumpers out there who think the bible
is the best book ever [ __ ] written
aside from the fact that when it was
written they still thought the [ __ ]
world was flat they thought if you were
gay you go to hell and all that other
intolerant horseshit in there but you
know I never read the [ __ ] thing so
you know let me know cuz this guy's
trying to acclaim trying to acclaim
trying to claim that they they address
dinosaurs in the Bible calling them
behemoths which is amazing considering
we never discovered the [ __ ] bones
until after the book was written so how
does that work huh was that when God was
a burning bush and all the fish was
coming out of the basket and he just
sort of muttered something about
behemoths and nobody understood it but
it was God so they just wrote it down
anyways is is that what you're going to
claim
oh Jesus Oh who can turn their world on
with her tits what did I want to talk
about this week how about the Bruins
Bruins making the [ __ ] playoffs I'm
predicting that the Bruins will once
again make it to the Eastern Conference
Finals and then then what's gonna happen
I'll tell you what's gonna happen is
they're not gonna go any further I don't
know I'm just gonna say that cuz
hopefully they'll prove me wrong who
knows we got a great goalie you know
what's scaring me is [ __ ] Carey Price
up in Montreal has been playing
fantastic alright and for some reason
when the Bruins have a great goalie it
only gets us so far but those sons of
[ __ ] up there with Ken Dryden Patrick
wah
back in [ __ ] 93 when they went on
that implausible run won like nineteen
overtime games one of the great runs at
winning the Stanley Cup of all [ __ ]
time who knows I don't know I think the
Flyers will beat them the Flyers never
seem to have problem with the Canadians
they don't give a [ __ ] all right they're
just gonna punch you in the face uh
anyways hey listen to this [ __ ] you know
something what happened to me twice this
week is people just they don't hear what
the [ __ ] I'm saying this is the classic
thing when you're doing stand-up comedy
you stand on stage and you tell a bunch
of jokes and everybody laughs
everybody's having just a great time and
then all of a sudden you come around to
a subject that touches a little close to
somebody's life and all of a sudden
you're not telling jokes anymore now
you're making statements well lo and
behold once again this happens I don't
know if you guys are aware of this but
my let it go special is now up on
Netflix the unedited version the version
that I wanted the world to see but that
dream was crushed because on Comedy
Central they have advertisers and that's
how they make their money which I
respect so then you know they got to cut
out some jokes they got to start doing
the Morse code because they say [ __ ]
every other word and then yadda yadda
yadda but now it's on Netflix now it's
on Netflix and you can watch that son of
[ __ ] completely unedited so please tell
your friends please tell your family
tell some of your enemies
so anyways so some some woman evidently
watch this watch my special my stand-up
comedy special the one where I go on and
act like an ass and I'm telling jokes
just to make you laugh just a [ __ ]
appease my ego that's all I'm doing so
anyways this lady starts off and she
says offended by your stay-at-home-mom
bit she starts off hi
obviously I'm a stay-at-home mom why is
that obvious because she said you're
offended by my stay-at-home mom bit why
couldn't you be just in a supporter of
stay-at-home moms oh I'm being a [ __ ]
right out of the gate let's read this
she starts off high obviously I'm a
stay-at-home mom and I love watching
stand-up but I couldn't continue
watching you based on your bit about
stay-at-home moms you know I love about
it it's an hour-long special and I think
I opened with that joke or it was
literally within the first five minutes
and she had to shut it off she says I'm
really sorry you feel that way about
stay-at-home moms that's one of my pet
peeves is when someone's about ready to
take the piss out of me I hate when they
apologize okay you're not sorry you're
not sorry that I feel that way you
[ __ ] hate me because I feel that way
alright stop apologizing oh god my voice
is cracking stop apologizing alright
anyway she goes and the
buh-buh-buh-buh-buh if it weren't for us
there would be no one to drill holes and
to do all the other important jobs that
you mentioned alright if it weren't for
you what do you just [ __ ] meditate
and you make a person you self-centered
[ __ ] [ __ ] can you believe she just
took credit for the creation of babies
100% credit what about the guy who
[ __ ] sticks it in yeah getting close
Oh what about that part of it but there
wasn't some hairy sweaty man pounding
away it's your [ __ ] womanhood to
completion I might add a number of times
during the course of a month two months
possibly three months if you got you
know if you got some sort of issue down
there for some reason you're living I
don't know what the [ __ ] I never try to
do it but I know you know we're having a
difficult time we're trying to get
pregnant but we're having a difficult
time it's not the [ __ ] part it's the
impregnation part she's just totally
taking away all of that that evidently
did she just sits there and all of a
sudden she's pregnant kind of like that
chick in the Bible hanging out with that
[ __ ] hippie bum Joseph right he's
sitting over in the corner with his
vaporizer Haney and I notice she looks
like you're putting on weight
man you got a lathe off the Dorito if
this man right and all of a sudden she's
[ __ ] pregnant so evidently this broad
she's taking full credit full credit for
getting pregnant completely ignoring the
man's part of it getting close oh that's
that's the noise I make when I climax by
the way I make I I announce to the
female in a really high-pitched voice
sort of a whiny voice I'm getting close
and then I put my mouth right next to
her ear and I go oh that's how it goes
down in my world um some of the most
sophomoric humor humor I've ever done
and right now there's a bunch of guys
laughing and there's a bunch of females
with their nose all wrinkled up this is
what you listen to this is what you
think it's funny yes [ __ ] this is what
I think's funny once you go back out in
the kitchen and finish making potato
salad
all right the fourth of July is coming
up I made no sense okay and if it
weren't for us there would be no one
drilling holes into
all the other important jobs that you
mentioned I didn't say they were
important I didn't say those jobs were
important you didn't even listen to the
bit let me continue reading here I said
Oprah said that being a mother is the
most difficult job in the planet if she
said it's the most important job I would
have gone with her but she said was the
most difficult job that's that right
there was the seed of the bit that I
created okay just like you creating the
[ __ ] kid but I don't feel like I
created the joke on my own
it took Oprah to say to toe to plant the
seed oh by saying by saying that it was
the most difficult job on the planet
alright that was her climaxing into my
joke [ __ ] oh that's disgusting
anyways so now I think everybody's
wrinkling their nose so here we go so
she continues after not even hearing
what I'm saying
and she said and the reason you stay in
your pajamas all day that was a line I
said talking about women is because you
don't have one minute to change try
taking a shower and putting on clothes
and clothes on with children screaming
and crying at the shower door it's 24/7
it never stops you don't click a time
card you never get off work it's 24/7
you have absolutely no idea until you're
in it I made a lot of money in my career
before motherhood motherhood
I earned my MBA and other degrees I've
lived and worked abroad motherhood is
the hardest job I've ever done I've
never said it's I've never said it's not
the hardest job that you've ever done
okay all right but I'm willing to bet
that you've never done a job harder than
working on a [ __ ] oil rig in the
middle of the ocean
alright sweetheart being a mom is not
more difficult than working on an oil
rig in the middle of the [ __ ] ocean
how about that guy out there who worked
on one and it [ __ ] blew up he's got
second degree burns on his back
if they're going to turn into
third-degree burns and he's eventually
going to explode into flames so his only
option is to jump basically the
equivalent of a three-story building he
jumps off it with his robbed burned up
back into the salt water of the ocean
also now covered in oil he's covered in
oil with second degree burns in salt
water okay he can barely [ __ ] breathe
the [ __ ] ocean is catching on fire
because of the oil that's on the surface
of the water he has to swim out of that
get out into the ocean but not get too
far away because he wants to get rescued
now he's got to sit there treading water
hoping he doesn't get eaten alive by
sharks or drown or dying I don't know
what else while he waits for the Coast
Guard to come and pick him up now you
tell me all the mothers out there I want
you to explain to me a day that was more
difficult than that and not only that
all this woman is doing is talking about
the negative aspects of being a mother
she's not talking about how rewarding it
is you don't get unconditional love from
a [ __ ] oil rig it's not gonna be
sitting there at your deathbed holding
your [ __ ] hand telling you that you
know the oil rig is everything it is
today because of you as a person give me
a [ __ ] break
all right and also you made the choice
to become a mother by letting that guy
get on top of you getting closer right
typical [ __ ] broad you're [ __ ] I
did she go anyway she continues your
joke is so offensive and so totally
wrong it's disgusting
another thing this is precious time to
me in the evening well I didn't good
lord what a [ __ ] she this is a mother
look at her working with the guilt this
is precious time to me in the evening
you were watching a stand-up special
that was gonna take a whole [ __ ] hour
you shut it off
seven minutes into it that gives you
next to 53 minutes to write two
paragraphs they're so full of [ __ ] so
anyways it's not she's trying to make me
feel guilty like I'm taking away from
her [ __ ] day another thing this is
precious time to me in the evening when
I can be taking a shower
read or watch a show and recharge for
the next day wait a minute
you just told me that being a mom was a
24/7 job
it never stops it never ends here you
are chilling out wanted to take a shower
read or watch a show and recharge for
the next day Jesus Christ she's go so
maybe later tonight when one of my
children get up I'm not on Facebook I
don't waste any time on the computer and
I don't complain about things but this
was so offensive that I made time for
this email I'll thank you thank you for
taking time out of your day you're
unbelievably 24/7 day and you just had
to say something then this is this is
awesome she this is how she answered
email she says very disappointed Jamie
actually never named names okay so this
is what I love about this this woman is
obviously gonna be a great mom okay
she's dedicated to it she's walked away
from her MBA career and all that type of
[ __ ] so she can focus on her career okay
but what you can see here is the
resentment that's already building
because she's already throwing out guilt
on to everybody that's what I love about
mothers all right no one told you to
become a mother
you made that [ __ ] choice and now you
actually have like resentment for your
[ __ ] job
and you starting to put it on your kids
I can tell you're already putting it on
your kids because you're trying to put
it on me you try to make me feel guilty
that you took the time to send me a
[ __ ] ID me I didn't ask you to send
me a [ __ ] email and then you end it
with very disappointed like I'm looking
for your approval see you're already
getting your god complex cuz your
[ __ ] kids are looking at you like you
know every goddamn answer on the planet
which you don't Jesus Christ
so there you go there you go people
there it is in a nutshell that's what
it's like to be a stand-up comedian you
make one [ __ ] joke okay about an
overstatement that someone said that
being a mother is the most difficult job
on the planet so what does that that
makes me think about all these other
jobs digging for coal you know being
President of the United States and
having this haven't decide that we're
gonna go to war and then you got to lay
to bed go lay in bed knowing that a
bunch of people are now gonna die
babies women you know 18 to 21 year old
[ __ ] people who signed up right out
of goddamn high school to be in the Army
Marines Navy you got it you got to make
that you got to lay in bed try and get
[ __ ] eight hours sleep with that [ __ ]
weighing on your head you know that that
was a joke it's not the most difficult
job on the planet if you said it's the
most important I would have gone with
that all right I I said I was arguing
that it wasn't the most difficult okay
and this is what happens people they
don't hear what you're saying and then
they go off on another tan
tangent like this other [ __ ] [ __ ]
this is a guy alright this guy what the
[ __ ] did he talk where the hell is it
oh Jesus bill oh Jesus look what you did
you just slowed the whole [ __ ] thing
down oh I disagree
he said bill loved the podcasts but I
disagree with you on the whole music
downloading thing most of my music that
I have that I have is not bought for
good reason first of all the last two
CDs I bought brand-new from the store
skipped in multiple CD players right out
of the box secondly artists only get
about five to ten percent five to ten
cents per CD which in the grand scheme
of things doesn't add up to much
compared to the money they get from
t-shirts and gigs now don't get me wrong
the people that just download thousands
of CDs worth of stuff and never go to
shows they're the douchebags I try to go
to at least five shows a year Wow and I
go to Lollapalooza in Chicago once every
three years so am ia loser to you
no you're not a loser you're just
stealing music you're stealing [ __ ]
music and you're trying to shine it all
up like hey man the artist doesn't make
any [ __ ] money you bought two CDs
from the store and they skipped in
multiple places dude you can go to
iTunes and you can download music in a
digital form and that doesn't skip all
right you try and justify the fact that
you steal thousands and thousands of
dollars worth of [ __ ] music and then
you spend you know a couple hundred
bucks on concert tickets and t-shirts
and [ __ ] and then and there you go I
didn't steal a hundred percent for you I
completely disagree with you I don't not
sayin you're a loser I'm saying you're a
thief you're stealing and you know
you're stealing all right
I'm not a musician dude I've bought CDs
I bought those things I know they start
to skip but if I buy him I [ __ ] upload
him onto my my computer but I do all of
my [ __ ] through iTunes but I don't I
don't steal music and when I did steal
it I addressed the fact that I was
stealing music I wasn't saying that I
wasn't part of the [ __ ] problem back
in the day when it first came out my
eyes [ __ ] dropped out of my head to
free music and I went to LimeWire and I
downloaded a couple hundred [ __ ]
songs but in the end when people
presented the argument dude you're
stealing I couldn't get around it I was
like yeah you're right I am so I stopped
so I'm not saying I'm better than you
and I'm not saying you're a [ __ ]
loser what I'm saying is you're stealing
[ __ ] music however you frame it and
go into a couple of concerts doesn't
make up for the fact that you stole the
music you know it's like concert tickets
cost money so I can concert ticket was
free and you made a donation you still
got something out of your money you got
a t-shirt you got a [ __ ] concert
ticket so you're acting like those
monies make up for the fact that you
stole music like you didn't get anything
out of the audit out of the concert
ticket and putting down money for a
t-shirt you got a [ __ ] Rock Show or a
hip-hop show whatever the [ __ ] you went
to and you got a t-shirt that doesn't
make up for the fact that you stole the
[ __ ] music it doesn't alright so like
I said I'm not saying you're
[ __ ] thief oh I'm on my goddamn high
horse here let's get two underrated
overrated here people a topic that I
thought was dying that I'm actually
pleased to say is is making a comeback
Oh before I do that I mentioned a few
weeks ago that the short film cheat that
me Joe DeRosa and Robert Kelley wrote
and acted in and Joe DeRosa did a
phenomenal job directing this movie the
short film we got it into the Tribeca
Film Festival which is one of the
biggest film festivals out there it's
right up there with Sundance and all
that type of stuff
and I wanted to give you guys the
screening times if you're actually in
the New York area and you want to come
down and support our film we would love
to see you down there we're gonna try to
hang out as as many screenings as we
possibly can there's a couple of them
that we're not allowed to go to just
because there's gonna be industry there
and they want to review the film and you
know we can't be breathing down their
necks making them uncomfortable so here
are the screening times Saturday April
23rd at 7 p.m. is the first screening of
course I don't have where this screening
I'm such a [ __ ] idiot
I'll give you this information I'll just
tell you when they are there Saturday at
7 p.m. Wednesday at 5:30 p.m. that's
April 27th and Saturday April 30th at 4
p.m. and Sunday May 1st at 7:30 p.m.
I believe I'm calling in the Opie and
Anthony show this week I believe
Thursday this week to Rosa and Bobby
Kelly are gonna be on there and we're
gonna have all the rest of the
information so I my what an idiot I am
why am i such a [ __ ] [ __ ] you know I
go to the mmm podcast com will it will
have the actual that's the official fan
page by the way and he gets all the [ __ ]
right I'm such a [ __ ] Moore I was so
excited to tell you guys all that type
of [ __ ] and what did i do what did i do
i [ __ ] the whole thing up alright feel
that do you hear that silence the
podcast is just screeched to a grinding
it's 100% my fault all right underrated
over it for this week
all right underrated this guy says ice
cream sandwiches they are made from the
cheapest ice cream and the crappiest
cookies but they are [ __ ] delicious
and I can eat like five I actually had a
debate with Nia on this one I thought he
was literally talking about ice cream
sandwiches but she's saying because he
said cookies he means those ones that
have like the chocolate chip cookies and
with that just that generic ice cream in
the middle it's basically you know the
filling that they put in hot dogs it's
the ice cream version of that and he
said he can eat like five and I am right
there with you I'm right there with you
I think I could he I think I could eat
six but I would get sick but I can eat
five just like you and I would not be
sick and my body at no point would be
acting like what I was doing was
incorrect until about 15 minutes later
when I suddenly would have to take a nap
never eat really bad food you have to
take a nap
you get all sleepy or as black people
call it the itis you get the itis I told
you that story a long time ago didn't I
I'll tell the t again the [ __ ] I got an
hour to kill here I know I got some new
listeners are now back in the day when I
was on the the Chappelle show tour and
it was me Charlie Murphy and Donnell
Rawlings who played ashy Larry we went
out in 2004 mid 2004 and toured I toured
I stayed on the tour till about the end
of February 2005 and these guys used to
break my balls about my shirts all my
clothes and all that type of [ __ ] that
actually turned into a bit when I did my
half hour special that whole bit that
month this [ __ ] only has five
shirts that came from hanging out with
those guys doing talent shows back in
the day
drew Fraser and all those guys Rob
Stapleton who are the room that I used
to do Capone's roams all those things
when I used to jump back and forth
between the black rooms white rooms some
mainstream rooms are uptown rooms as
they used to call them but anyways so
these guys used to you know I think she
just give me [ __ ] and that type of stuff
so we had gone out drinking or I had
gone out drinking I was brutally [ __ ]
hungover
and I just didn't want to listen to that
[ __ ] and we were driving from Chicago
up to Vernon Hills to do the zany's up
there and it was a good hour
hour-and-a-half drive I don't know what
what I was gonna see him like five hours
and I could tell that they were just
gonna be [ __ ] on my [ __ ] because I
was really hungover so what I did was I
asked the do I don't somehow I can't I
walked out to try to get some fresh air
and I saw that there was a Popeye's
Chicken like [ __ ] two blocks up so I
ran up there and got like a [ __ ] I
don't know a 17 piece of that [ __ ] with
biscuits and all of that [ __ ]
we were leaving right around 11:00 and
we go and we get in the [ __ ] limo to
go up there and I bring hey guys I got
us some food
and I ate one piece and watched them
devour like another five six pieces a
couple of biscuits right and they were
already giving me [ __ ] and within
[ __ ] 15 minutes they were [ __ ]
sound asleep and I just sat there with
the smile on my face with some of that
greasy food in my stomach but not enough
to make me fall asleep just enough to
feel comfortable comforted right and I
had my sunglasses on and I cruised
although we cruised all the way up there
and they slept the whole [ __ ] way
it's one of the brilliant moves and my
stand-up career um so anyways oh
speaking of that [ __ ] I'm actually
getting myself into great shape here you
want to know how I've been doing it well
I don't give a [ __ ] gonna tell you
anyway I mentioned it back in the day I
got a juicer and like most things you
know when you get something new you're
all about it you're all about it for
like I don't know what right a week two
weeks maybe a month and then one day you
just blow it off you just [ __ ] blow
it off and then it starts gathering dust
and then every once in a while you just
look at whatever you bought your iPad
you [ __ ] I don't know what your
whatever gadget you had it's just over
there collecting dust and you just have
that feeling like god I used to be so
[ __ ] into that thing you know it's
kind of like a relationship you know you
meet some hot girl you're telling your
friends do this one of the hottest
[ __ ] chicks I've ever been with she's
got like the perfect
it's you ever do that you start
describing a body to all your [ __ ]
animal guy friends and then all of a
sudden it turns into a relationship you
know and now it's your girlfriend and
now you know I described the tits to my
friends or the [ __ ] crazy things she
did in bed you know and then what
happened she's totally into her you
banging your bang and you banging and
then just one day you don't even notice
it is not into it anymore yeah and then
one day you're walking by and you looked
in is your [ __ ] just gathering dust
like you [ __ ] laserdisc player and
you're wondering what the [ __ ] happened
you know and that's the moment will you
realize if you're with the right person
or not because if you decide that you're
gonna work at the relationship and get
the sparks going again you're with the
right person but if you're just looking
at it like a [ __ ] old VCR it's time
to move on that's what I think so
anyways let's get back to the juicer
everybody so the juicer evidently is my
[ __ ] gadget soulmate because I looked
at it and I was getting sad going you
know what I got a [ __ ] I gotta get
this thing back in my life I gotta find
where where did we lose the magic so I
went to the health food store and I went
in there like a little [ __ ] you know
vegan I [ __ ] go in there right oh you
know what's funny this this place right
around the corner from where I live
sells that coconut water that I
absolutely love that I drank on Joe
Rogan show and that they told me they
got on amazon.com and I ordered it on
amazon.com
you know me I'm totally [ __ ] I got
the OCD like or whatever right when I
get into [ __ ] I get into [ __ ] and it was
like 20-something bucks to get like like
twelve of these things so it was already
expensive and then you know if if you
know you just do five to six business
days who gives a [ __ ] they charge you
like three bucks but I was like no I
want that [ __ ] in two days so my
shipping cost was as much as the goddamn
price of the coconut I'd like 40 bucks
for 12 of them and then I go down the
street when I when I reintroduce my
off to my juicer going hey baby let's
you know what happened to us man let's
watch a movie tonight right I go over to
the [ __ ] in a vegetable place oh you
know what that creepy little analogy
just reminded me of I guess there's some
[ __ ] show out there where people are
in love with inanimate objects like they
actually like [ __ ] a fence or a bridge
or they want to like marry the Eiffel
Tower can somebody please tell me what
that show is I really want to watch that
because I saw that one that was fatal
fatal attractions where people have wild
animals that they try to turn to try to
turn into uh they try to turn into pets
and that those people were just so
[ __ ] stupid to me that I couldn't
watch the show but I ended up hearing
that that show was good cuz they get him
they get into the psychology of why
somebody gets into that all ice when I
saw that guy with the Buffalo walking
around his house and every time he
walked by him that Buffalo would slam
him into the wall and he looked like
Wayne Gretzky getting [ __ ] checked by
any sort of [ __ ] normal sized hockey
player and he'd just be like no as he
would walk by that she just playing
she's just playing this it was so
[ __ ] stupid I couldn't watch it so if
anybody can tell me what the name of
that show is where people are like in
love with like a door you know dude how
much alone time are you spending I mean
I haven't heard that in jail well he
didn't solitary confinement do you get
in love with the walls I bet you do at
some point some point you just you just
from just lack of human contact you know
that man brain kicks in will you get
visually stimulated you got to get
visually stimulated by something and
they would just be like I bet it's like
at some point during the day when the
Sun starts going down right and the
shadow just hits the wall a certain way
he just there you are there you are you
sweet little naughty naughty piece of
plaster well you've been for the last 23
hours
I want to hear it you know that's
[ __ ] creepy actually somebody's
probably in jail or has been in jail is
gonna be Oh actually when you're in
solitary confinement there's no sunlight
alright whatever whatever the [ __ ] it is
you [ __ ] the floor you know there you go
is that in any prison book I think I hit
my low point when I was consistently
[ __ ] the floor alright let's continue
one here so anyway so I got my juicer
back in my life that's what the [ __ ] I'm
trying to tell you so I go to the
goddamn health food store right and you
know it's great about going to the
health food stores even though the
aisles are really skinny much skinnier
than one of the grocery stores those
[ __ ] you know people who actually eat
healthy or they're just waif human
beings they do yoga little wispy little
you know those dogs little whippets they
just like them you know walking up and
down the aisles with their [ __ ] tail
between their legs trying to pick out
zucchini so I'm going in there right
suddenly feeling like I'm on roids
because I look so much bigger ab full of
[ __ ] there was a couple decent sized
people in there but whatever so I go in
there I pick out all this [ __ ] fruits
and vegetables to juice so that's how
I've been starting my day people start
my day I [ __ ] juice then I go get my
[ __ ] pit bull we go for a walk we go
for a hike for like an hour I come back
and then I have a bowl of oatmeal with
with some a handful of raisins thrown in
there that's how I start my day and it's
been [ __ ] great for me I'm not trying
to preach to you people I'm not trying
to be a [ __ ] breakfast Nazi here but
I'm this is what I realized with me this
is how I get out of wack is if I start
my day either with I can't even just say
toast and eggs but if I if I throw the
bacon in there then it's really extra
salty then I got to throw a little jam
on my toast you know to try to level
myself off just like a [ __ ] cokehead
drinking alcohol to bring me down a
little bit you know I got the salt the
salts making me sleepy so I put the
jelly on the toast to bring me back up
right there I'm out of [ __ ] whack or
if I have french toast or anything you
put syrup on then my sugar goes through
the roof next thing you know I'm
grabbing a handful of [ __ ] potato
chips you know like an hour
and then like for the rest of the day my
blood sugar I don't know what it is it
probably looks like a what do you got
one of the one of those things with uh
the heart thing
sonogram whatever the [ __ ] you call it
not a telegraph what do you call that
[ __ ] thing you know when you when you
when you're lay there in the hospital
and they're they're looking at your
heart rate that's what that's what it
looks like salt sugar salt sugar that's
what I do for the rest of the [ __ ]
day and then in the end of the day I
take a big piece of cake and I shove it
right down my [ __ ] pie hole and
that's my day and then gradually my
white doughy stomach starts to hang over
my belt and then I hate myself and then
I start lashing out of people in the
crowd so there you go that's what's been
working for me um so why don't why don't
you guys give a shot if you want to if
you don't I don't give a [ __ ] oh by the
way 170 days without booze and I
actually [ __ ] it up yesterday
I was at a part of barbecue yesterday
and I accidentally twice had two sips of
beer okay so technically in my world my
streak is still going because it was an
accident but I I've I've had booze
within the last 24 hours and this is
this is what I've noticed what is really
fascinating about the human brain and I
didn't realize this until I went to
Stockholm Sweden when I did that gig
over there member I told you that story
and I went over there and everybody you
know and I forgot that you know I didn't
speak a word of Swedish and everyone's
going tries and tries in cars your
version and I was good you know the
[ __ ] the comedian in front of me who
was speaking English backstage went out
there and did his whole act in Swedish
and was killing fries recharging ours
our Harjit Sajjan the crowds like oh and
I'm freaking out going to they even got
a [ __ ] understand me this is what I
learned when I was in Sweden was I took
for granted how much I don't read when
I'm in the States because you just like
I think when you look at a stop sign you
don't read stop you just you're just
visually looking at it and I didn't
realize that [ __ ] until I went over to
Sweden and the amount of extra thinking
that I had to do where I would be
looking at like a car and just be like
okay is that a taxi or is that a police
car you know or I'd have to look at a
storefront and just sort of try to
because I can't read the word it's in
Swedish and it's like 97 [ __ ] letters
I'd have to just really sit there
looking is that close is there is there
food in there is that what the [ __ ] is
that that's what happened to me at the
party I opened the refrigerator door and
I saw this green can
and I immediately equated it with soda
and I said and my brain told me it was a
sprite turned out it was 7up and right
next to it was a red and white can so I
think I actually think it was just red
so in my world that was Coke so I
reached for the coke opened it up took a
sip of it thinking I was drinking
coca-cola and it was a Mexican beer and
I drank it I didn't even recognize a
weird tasting beer I thought it was like
iced tea and I look down and I'm reading
it you know actually I'm just looking
for Coke then I'm looking all over the
words then finally I see beer I'm like
is this did I just drink a beer I was
like [ __ ] there goes my goddamn streak
so of course Nia's laughing at me so
then I go over and grab what I thought
was a sprite was actually 7up I started
drinking that and then later on the
Beano at the party you grabbed the wrong
thing once again I I thought I was
drinking coke and I reached over and I
grabbed it not another thing another
[ __ ] swig of beer so I want you guys
to know is my streak over you know all
you addicts out there what does that
mean if you if you do that if you're an
a a do you have to turn in your chip and
start all over again and go up there and
cry at the podium because you actually
had a sip of beer do I get any credit
with the fact that I that I opened the
beer took the sip of the beer and just
said oh [ __ ] this is you know I thought
this was coke it's a beer and I just set
it down I didn't have anymore
anybody can you help me out here this is
when I wish I took callers I'm glad I
don't take callers because I think
collars really slow down the [ __ ]
show you know half of them are [ __ ]
prank phone calls and then half the
people it just takes them too goddamn
long plus I like talking all right you
haven't noticed the fact that I rarely
have a guest
this show and I could somehow keep it
going for a [ __ ] hour you know that's
not an amazing ability that's that is an
incredible personality fluff all right
more underrated overrated unpaid
internships overrated I graduated from
college less than a year ago and have
been looking for a job in my area of
studies for more than a year with no
success dude my heart goes out to these
[ __ ] kids just getting out to come
out of college right now and the one of
the worst economies ever it's just
[ __ ] ridiculous they already
overcharged you for your [ __ ]
education and these goddamn bankers
screwed the whole [ __ ] economy up
anyways plumbing ahead he says while
looking for a job I encountered numerous
agencies that offer internships but no
but none for pay it seems how is that
legal by the way you don't pay him
anything it seems like many places take
advantages of the bad economy and the
desperate job seekers to lure them into
doing work for free unfortunately I'm
one of them dude what kind of a [ __ ]
scumbag this is what you know I want to
go undercover into corporate America and
I want to I want to see how that goes
down how that how it like is it just
like the mob were you like a it's not
[ __ ] personal it's business you know
well if you if you check out the market
what the market will bear now is it's
advantageous if you're the employer to
not to take advantage of the human
resources and offer them a negative cash
flow contract however they [ __ ] do
they never just come out and say hey
let's take advantage of the future and
pay them absolutely nothing so we can we
can drive we can put rims on our flashy
[ __ ] cars anyways he says what do
these agencies offer in exchange
experience building your resume making
connections with other employees
promises of hiring after a short period
and other
[ __ ] like that he says [ __ ] that and
capital letters you mentioned in Joe
Rogan's podcast how comedians should not
offer their material for free in
exchange for exposure and I completely
agree these unpaid internships that are
so popular right now need to stop I'm
more efficient than some of my full-time
co-workers at my internships which are
not a surprise oh wait which are not a
surprise are part of a workers union and
I work here comes my bad reading skills
I got totally confused with his
parentheses he says and I worked there
only two days out of the week if it
wasn't funny it would be sad so he's
basically saying in those two days he
does more work than the people who are
members of the Union you know that's
something that unions have to address
here is I'm all about unions but you
know just because you now have the power
to lean on a shovel doesn't mean you
should and that's what's really [ __ ]
over unions unions were a great idea and
people died had their heads kicked in
got shot at by our own [ __ ] army when
guys like Andrew Carnegie had the
connections to bring them in like he did
there and the [ __ ] banks of the
Allegheny out there in Pittsburgh or
wherever the [ __ ] it was at that's now a
mall all right they needed those unions
so we could avoid sweatshop the
sweatshop labor conditions that existed
in this country and then what happened
aside from the map the mob taken over
those things what happened is is guys
use the unions the power of unions as a
way to get over [ __ ] paid and not to
bust their ass at work anymore so then
they became the exact [ __ ] thing that
they were rebelling against so I
understand why corporations move their
their [ __ ] companies out of this
country I also understand why that there
had to be Union said you know this is
what it always comes down to is people
are people rich people aren't the only
greedy [ __ ] [ __ ] out there you
know middle-class and poor people if you
put them in a position where they can be
greedy this
thing is most people will take advantage
of this situation this is not these and
these are not unique theories this is
the overall theory harsh theory that
most people learn when they can when
they get out of their house and they get
into the real world you realize that
most people are [ __ ] there's very few
good people out there poor middle class
or [ __ ] rich there's very few people
that'll actually do the right thing
so I 100% agree with that it would be
you know speaking of unions it would be
great if you could somehow start one you
know that's what you need to do is you
need to get everybody on the same page
and say listen we're not saying you got
to give us all of us but this [ __ ]
working for free is ridiculous
yeah they totally taken advantage of you
because of the market but I guess if
it's a good market you guys can take
advantage of them I don't know man it's
just so I don't know who the [ __ ] knows
but I definitely did there's just
something wrong with having kids work
for [ __ ] free all right and I will
say to people who were in unions which I
am 100 supported in support of you
[ __ ] need to work harder and
you'll have a better you'll have a
better public image now I'm not saying
everybody in unions don't you know they
all of them lean on shovels but you know
why you got that reputation
okay I'm Irish I know we got why we got
the reputation for being a bunch of
drunk [ __ ] because so many of
us are or at least enough of us got so
[ __ ] drunk that we completely wiped
out any sort of good Irishmen out there
alright so there you go another one
documentaries underrated in the last few
months I've become a big fan of
documentaries especially about Korah our
corrupted economy our [ __ ] up culture
in our diet dying planet and environment
I have to say these films put a really
great picture as far as our civilization
goes yeah I know that's why I kind of
stopped watching them I just try to do
the right thing in my own life if I if I
watch too many of those they they really
depressed the [ __ ] out of me the
president is already looking bad and I
do not see a way we can dig ourselves
out of this hole that we've created I
just don't understand why people dismiss
these types of films are they trying to
avoid the painful truth absolutely
just said I was are they in denial
absolutely there are ways and solutions
to fix it but as long as we have
Democrats versus Republicans white
versus black versus first Hispanics coal
and oil energy versus clean energy and
most importantly [ __ ] paper money in
stock markets nothing's gonna change dad
this guy this is this is the exact
conclusion that I came to although I
don't agree that a lot of the clean
energy they say is clean energy like as
much as I Drive a hybrid which is really
a scam it's only an electric car when
it's going five miles an hour
under other than that it's just an
underpowered gas car but it does burn
clean and it does get great gas mileage
but you know electric cars I mean those
batteries eventually you have to dispose
of those and those things wreak havoc
basically human beings in general wreak
havoc on the environment so I think the
solution is you have to have some sort
of population control and they should do
it sooner rather than later because if
they did it sooner we could avoid some
sort of Stalin esque slash Hitler
solution because that's what the [ __ ]
they're gonna do I think the problem
with human beings is we treat global
problems the same way we ecology kid
treats doing a term paper we do it the
night before you know remember y2k we
knew that [ __ ] was coming and ended up
not being a [ __ ] problem but
everybody panicked in the final two
months they were talking about it for
ten years that we were gonna have this
possibly have this [ __ ] problem and
we waited until the last [ __ ] second
and I think that the population problem
is going to be the same thing the
problem there's too many [ __ ] people
there's no there's nothing wrong with
chopping down trees there's nothing
wrong with using coal there's nothing
wrong with driving a big car there's
nothing wrong with any of that the
problem is is that there's 7 billion
people on the [ __ ] planet that
because that's a problem all right we
need to get that number way the [ __ ]
down way the [ __ ] down I would say under
a billion under a billion people you
need to do that so I think that you
should just implement laws the amount of
people that kids that you can have
and I also think that you know you
should offer people money if they to not
have kids adopt kids recycle I think
that they should do all of that type of
stuff while they try to have cleaner
burning cars in that type of [ __ ] and
just gradually let people kind of die
off you know that's that's what I feel
you know cuz if you don't do that then
eventually I think that we're gonna run
out of food run out of clean water and
you're gonna have the rich in their
gated communities and they're gonna be
guarded by the Blackwater people and
they're just gonna be shooting out the
rest of us and their [ __ ] heads in
our heads that's that's what I think is
gonna happen personally you know if
Mother Nature doesn't get us first all
right that was uplifting all right let's
get to uh let's get to advice for the
week bill a year and a half ago a year
and a half ago me and this girl that I
used to work with we're hanging out a
lot and fooling around all summer very
nice it was pretty casual there you go
that's how you set it up it's pretty
casual wonderful now I think in just the
art is trying to keep it there and as
I've told you before what that is it's
it's the time between your hooking up
okay when you keeping a casual on that
type of [ __ ] if you want to hang out and
have drinks that's fine
but when you get back to your place you
do the deed and that's it she's got to
go you can't hang out and watch a movie
that's when they start getting feelings
it's not fair to the female you know
that's what you got to do don't call him
all the [ __ ] time you got to keep it
[ __ ] casual alright continuing which
is kind of hard to do when you work with
her but anyways he goes it was pretty
casual but that was only because we both
knew I had to leave in August so he made
a point to not get too sir serious
beautiful once the summer ended I had to
go back to school in Miami so our
situation kind of ended but we stayed in
touch then recently this last spring
break I went home for ten days when I
let her know I was going to be in town
she said that that we had to hang out
but only his friends because she had a
boy
friend which I was fine with all right
dude now but I haven't read this one yet
but I gotta tell you right here don't
hang out with her more than once all
right this is what you should do in that
situation she's got a boyfriend it's
over all right
so if she wants to hang out hang out in
a public place and at the end of the
night you say you gotta go don't bring
up sex don't [ __ ] do anything like
what you used to do she's got a
boyfriend you got to walk away from that
situation not to mention if you - you
were just hanging out at any moment her
boyfriend could walk in you could get
the old [ __ ] clattering to the side
of the [ __ ] head
anyways so the first day I was there she
came over to my house to hang out okay
that's it that's a red flag right there
she's got a boyfriend you come to town
she immediately drops her boyfriend it
comes to hang out with you all right
after a half hour of that awkward
catching up conversation we went up to
my room to watch a movie oh Jesus
once the movie started she made sure to
drive home the fact that I shouldn't
make a move on her because she's with
someone else yes he right here dude
she's playing with you dick she's
slapping it around making it go up and
then she's going hey hey hey hey we got
to take it easy and then it goes back
down again she's [ __ ] with you she's
[ __ ] with you she's playing the up
and down game from the Opie and Anthony
show with you dick if you guys haven't
seen that yet I'm telling you look that
up on YouTube the Opie and Anthony
up-and-down game it's one of the most
genius bits I've ever seen [ __ ]
hilarious
anyways I completely disregarded this oh
so she tells you yeah yeah yeah let me
let me go back here
I really have to drop my commentary here
why don't I just read the rest here um
so the movie starts and she drives on
the point that they shouldn't yeah he
shouldn't make a move on her because
she's she is with somebody else so he
says I completely disregard this and I
put my arm around her anyways ten
minutes into the movie
you know what I respect that move by the
way 10 minutes into the movie we're in a
full-on cuddle and she's doing that [ __ ]
was she's running her finger up and down
my arm then out of nowhere she flips
around and climbs on top of me with that
[ __ ] me looking her eyes dude this is a
great story
she even she's even doing that pre sex
slightly heavy breathing dude I'm not I
haven't read this I'm telling you she's
gonna pull the emergency chute this is
the Richard Pryor bit where they wit T a
dick is hard enough to cut diamonds I
believe is how Richard put it or mr.
Pryor let me have some [ __ ] respect
here saying Richard like I know the guy
she drops in to start kissing me but
stops an inch from my mouth and stays
there for a second or two then she
climbs off and goes back to cuddling oh
you know I do you're young you didn't
know any better but if you were older
you set yourself up for this
after recollecting myself I started to
say something but the second I started
talking she flipped over and did it
again but for a bit longer this time
this time I asked her what the [ __ ] she
was doing and she giggled [ __ ]
yeah dude right there man this is the
thing you got to take charge of the
situation
you got to tell you dick to stand down
and be like look either we're gonna do
this so we're not gonna do this this is
I actually think at that point you
should have just bounced her out of
there and rubbed one out that's the
power move right there man that's the
move that's gonna make you feel better
than if you even [ __ ] her because
she's still gonna get something out of
it she got to get laid right so [ __ ] dad
you should have kicked her out right
down just Benedict you know what this
was a bad idea shut this off you have to
go you shouldn't be doing this you have
a boyfriend
see you flip it around you put the guilt
on her she leaves you [ __ ] rub one
out right then you don't give a [ __ ]
that she didn't bang her and then you
[ __ ] go out to the local watering
hole you know you got a run into some
chick he went to [ __ ] high school
with you're a little older you little
more manly get the scruff going and you
[ __ ] tag her and [ __ ] this girl she
is
she has a boyfriend she shouldn't be
doing this [ __ ] all right let's continue
um where the hell was I this time though
she stayed she did it for about full 30
seconds okay so we went back to cuddling
for the next five minutes until she did
it for a third time this time though she
stayed there for about 30 seconds and
she wouldn't pull and she would pull
back every time I actually kiss her so
that she kept the inch between us once
she got off she started that giggling
again which by then had gone from cute
to annoying as hell and then slipped her
shoes on and said she had to go see dude
if you took charge in one of those you
could have bounced her out we didn't
hang out again after that and now I'm
back on Miami I guess my question is
what should I have done I guess I
already answered it and what the [ __ ]
was she doing any answer would be great
or even a rant about those annoying tees
and [ __ ] thanks well you know what dude
I hadn't read this one
I was busy this week and my the guy who
helps me with my podcast will remain
nameless because that's how I do it sent
me this thing and I'm a little late
today so it's the first time I read it
um yeah that's what she was doing she
just I don't know you'd almost have to
ask a female to get into the psychology
of it but I could I guess like I think
that I don't know does she want to just
see that you still want to [ __ ] her and
that like I can tell you this right now
that her relationship with this other
guy isn't gonna work and she has major
[ __ ] that major she's good she's
either really immature or eventually she
has major issues and she'll [ __ ] up
every relationship by doing [ __ ] like
this and eventually she's gonna be that
old hottie hanging out at the wine bar
you know with the crow's feet around her
eyes you know
you know that chick she'll just send me
end up being that girl and then we'll
look back in regret at all the good guys
that she [ __ ] dick teased as she was
playing the [ __ ] field but this is
what you do in the future the second a
girl is doing some [ __ ] like that the
second she said listen just so you know
I have a boyfriend we can
be doing this you should have said you
know what you're right let's not watch a
movie and right then you kick her out so
you have some sort of power all right
and if you want to [ __ ] a girl like that
you should have been the one saying no
you should have been the one pushing her
off all right because it sounds like she
has that [ __ ] thing where you know
she gets off on the fact that you want
her but can't have her all right
so if you're acting like you don't want
her that [ __ ] with her head like wait a
minute what am I losing my [ __ ] power
and you just literally back your way
into the [ __ ] boat then you Club her
over the head and then there you go you
got your fish in the boat all right
that's how you do that but I got to tell
you in the future dude chicks like that
are just a complete [ __ ] waste of
time
you're already banged her so you already
dotted all the eyes crossed all the t's
what the [ __ ] he's still doing you're
there because it's an easy you thought
it was an easy [ __ ] lay when you got
back which is understandable okay but
the problem is is you don't have your
dick and check your dick is running your
[ __ ] life you got to make the
decisions all right and when you [ __ ]
do that you start winning those a lot
more see women have their [ __ ] in
check that's why they always win those
battles 90% of the [ __ ] time so there
you go that's the little information
that I can help you with what I like I
said don't ever don't ever be afraid to
[ __ ] ask a female for advice on stuff
like that not only will they give you
advice they actually enjoy doing it and
they'll have way better advice than I do
because you know because they're a
[ __ ] woman you know what I mean
it's like you calling me you're asking a
plumber about [ __ ] carpentry go to a
carpenter all right that is the podcast
for this week I hope you guys hope you
guys enjoyed it seemed like a fairly
smooth one right um let me can I pour
out some dates here people can you hang
with me this long enough huh well maybe
you're gonna hang with me because you're
on final approach oh you know what I
can't stand this is what happened me the
other day I went out to go buy my
[ __ ] water cooler that I want to have
just in case of tsunami hits out here
because I live on a fault line and I
always want to have at least five to ten
gallons of water you know I'm already
inland enough with the tsunamis not
going to hit
if a tsunami hits me here I'm telling
you Utah's in trouble alright so I go to
Lowe's hardware I go there online I look
up to see if they have the one that I
want and then you know and Lowe's has it
so rather than just saying they only
have it online I'm assuming it's at the
[ __ ] store so I jump in my car and I
Drive over there and they they don't
[ __ ] have it
they don't [ __ ] have it and it's just
you know just [ __ ] drove me nuts so
then I stopped off a sporting goods
store to buy a pump because my football
doesn't have any air in it and this is
what you do at 42 when you don't have
any [ __ ] kids you know you actually
you're still acting like you [ __ ] 14
so I don't know I just had that moment
when I went into the sporting goods
store you know I hate when they can't
[ __ ] help me I'm asking a simple
question and then I start to flip out
and then they just call me sir a million
[ __ ] times you know sir I'm sorry sir
but circuits you sir could you please
not sharing the sir please sir thank you
sir that [ __ ] [ __ ]
that's what reminds me of flying on the
plane if you do anything if you have
your seat back sir could you please put
your seat back up sir thank you sir sir
in order to expedite this sir sir could
you please sir I [ __ ] hate that and I
thought that you know what I do then I
through gritted teeth just say ma'am
back a hundred times I'm sorry ma'am yes
man thank you ma'am ma'am could you stop
ma'aming me ma'am
you [ __ ] [ __ ] ma'am I'm sorry that
was a little bit of [ __ ] half ounce
of rage I had to get out there let me
get back to - my dates here so anyways
this week
oh what a week I have I'm gonna be at
the record theater for two shows I
believe the second show has already sold
out so if you want to get tickets you
better [ __ ] hustle there for you
[ __ ] [ __ ] it's the goddamn internet
weren't not working in this room you
know I really need to step my life up
I'm at the record theater this this
Friday April 8th for two shows I believe
they're like eight and ten or eight and
10:30 I don't know what the [ __ ] they
are my goddamn website won't come up
that's in Baltimore outside of Baltimore
Maryland
and on Friday night I'm at the tower
Tower Theatre in Philadelphia
Pennsylvania later on this month I got
two more shows one is in Milwaukee
Wisconsin April 22nd at the Pabst
Theater unbelievable response by the way
I want to thank everybody beforehand in
Milwaukee maybe that's why I had the
Laverne & Shirley song in my head isn't
that where that show was based at and he
also worked at a beer factory it's all
coming full circle and on the 23rd I'll
be at the Royal Oak Theatre in Detroit
Michigan both of those dates are selling
unbelievably well both of them are gonna
sell out so get your tickets as soon as
you can and I want to thank everybody
there for like I have not I've never
played Milwaukee and I have not played
Detroit since I did the rich [ __ ] tour
the Chappelle show tour back and I think
I did that in Oh for III all I've done
is I've done like kickers and that type
of stuff outside of Troy Detroit but I
haven't been in Detroit so I guess it's
Royal Oak I have no idea and then the
last one is actually sold out it's one
of those antisocial comedy comedy tour
dates and that one is Jim Norton put the
tour together Jim Norton from Little
Jimmy from the Opie and Anthony show
best radio show out there for my money
Jim Norton Jim Breuer Dave Attell and
myself are all doing a comedy tour we
just added some dates we have a date in
Washington DC on May 13th we have one in
June I believe it's at the Chicago
theater these are all at antisocial
comedy calm I believe that one is June
15th I think I don't know all of that is
on antisocial comedy calm just click on
tour dates those dates are all on sale
you know please calm down you get you
get four comics for the price of one
we're playing some of the most beautiful
venues in the country more dates are
gonna follow because the turnout has
been unbelievable ticket sales have been
fantastic so that's the podcast for this
week
Oh real quick Jay Miller one of my
favorite enforcers of the Boston Bruins
is in in the hospital recovering from
pneumonia just want to send him
get-well-soon wishes I'm one of my
favorites and we're gonna send a link
YouTube video we got some great YouTube
videos this week I almost forgot about
those we're gonna have one of Jay Miller
holding his own against the greatest of
all time for my money Bob Probert and
what are the YouTube videos for this
week oh we got some good ones I got one
from that show cheaters you know that
show cheaters where the guy you know
they basically somebody thinks that
somebody's cheating on them so then what
do they do they get they hired this
company and they start spying on the
boyfriend and girlfriend and when they
confirm that they are in fact cheating
they show up and confront them and this
is one of the greatest ones I've ever
seen they confront this kid at at an ice
rink after he just played a hockey game
and you know usually the person who's
cheating you know the dude is absolutely
stunned this guy handles it absolutely
perfectly he [ __ ] breaks up with her
she shows up she's like you know cuz the
chick he's cheating with is at the ice
rink she says yeah who the [ __ ] is that
you know what the [ __ ] are you doing
here and he just goes he just breaks up
with her right on the spot he's leaning
on his stick white wiping the snow I
mean the the sweat off of his [ __ ]
nose he looks like a hockey player in
between periods going like yeah we got
to work on our for checking and I hope
we can get that gold back in the second
period
he wasn't even sweating it he just
breaks up with her she's like yeah who
the [ __ ] is that what the [ __ ] are you
doing he just goes he goes yeah we're
done what do you what do you mean went
done just like that he goes yeah it's
over she goes that girl because the
other girl was uglier she goes you're
gonna dump me for that girl and he goes
what can I say she she does it right and
he didn't he didn't give a [ __ ] he was
barely looking at her he was just
sitting there leaning on his stick he
wasn't nervous that there was cameras
there and he just [ __ ] breaks up with
her and then his girlfriend doesn't know
what to do she's so she ends up getting
into a fistfight with the chickies
cheating on and he just sawed it walks
away into the locker room
it's [ __ ] phenomenal um what else do
we got we have some hippie chick trying
to give a presentation to a bunch of
corporate people what the hell are these
YouTube videos we got Paul Orndorff
hyping the Hulk Hulkamania workout thing
that's one of my favorites and we got a
couple others they're all gonna be up at
the mm podcast.com and like I stated
earlier if you want to send emails to
this podcast the new email address is
bill at the mm podcast.com please keep
them coming you guys emails they get
better each week that's it you guys all
have a great weekend great weekend great
week all right
go [ __ ] yourselves I'll talk to you next
week
[Music]
you